ce soir des victimes de la route
deviennent victimes de la salle dans
chaque village une situation
catastrophique de perdre de leur maison
leur conjoint père de touche la main des
accidentés qui conteste les réclamations
la société d'assurance automobile du
québec se retrouve parfois sans salaire
et sans indemnité réel un rapport
médical ne sera pas suffisant ça n'en
prend 2 après ça ça prend une expertise
vous appréciez une contre-expertise
cette expertise en bout des cas les
victimes tombent en cause ses frais
d'experts ne sont pas remboursés d'une
part le mieux-être des québécois moi ça
me préoccupe terriblement dans ce
domaine de l'assurance du monde où je
veux être sûr que ce qu'on va apporter
c'est un mieux-être dans un deuxième
temps une sorte de justice sociale en
1978 lise payette créé l'assurance
automobile du québec
on voulait indemniser les accidentés de
la route mais ça recherché de coupables
et surtout mettre un terme aux longues
poursuites judiciaires contre les
assureurs privés
au volet un système plus simple et plus
humain mais quarante ans plus tard cette
assurance qui devait nous protéger
koné des dérapages
si pour la très grande majorité des ex
tenté de la route
les réclamations à la société
d'assurance automobile du québec se
termine bien lorsqu'un accidenté
conteste les choses se compliquent les
délaisse s'accumulent et se comptent en
ami
[Musique]
tonnerre de critiques venues de succès
ce qu'il faut paraît certain de mes
patientes qui ont passé dans ces
différents tribunaux
c'est un découragement absolue j'ai
l'impression que nos chances
raisonnables de gagner diminue à vue
d'oeil au lieu que ce soit une loi à
caractère social qui doit favoriser
l'indemnisation c'est de plus en plus
traitée comme une compagnie d'assurance
les victimes de la route deviennent des
victimes de la société de l'assurance
automobile du québec
excusez je vais dire des changes est à
la télévision qu'on devrait pas me les
gens de la saq au popcorn
[Musique]
ce matin gérard la france veut nous
amener à son atelier mais cela commence
difficilement
dès que tu force le moindrement ton coup
fait mal
faux petit force c'est moi la femme
forte
ses soeurs piscénois
pourtant gérard la france est un dur à
l' ouvrage l'atelier a été cette vie la
mécanique sa passion il a eu un accident
travail avant d'avoir un accident de
voiture
c'est étrange à dire mais ce sera sa
chance dans son infortune
il nous fera découvrir les failles du
système
comme vous le verrez du show débute
cette donc alors c'est espèce de force
brute qui travaille toujours fort dans
son coin à faire des fermes de camions
des cloches sans arrêt quand même gérard
réduit à 4 8 sa capacité morale mais
l'accident d'auto impliquant des
camionnettes une remorque une roulotte à
me fait un retour au travail prévu
c'était en 2014
ça brûle des voitures là dessus une
scène est trop limité aux péris d'hasbro
gym usera déchiré mais à côté des
réparations un but plus le coup du coup
ceux plus capable mais pour la société
de l'assurance auto ce n'est pas dû à
l'accident voiture la presse paperasse
60 des fois jeté un petit peu perdues je
trouvais de sectes et une coque d'à
50 de paperasse de contestation et ce
n'est pas terminé
un délai qui n'est pas si inhabituel on
retourne au 8 janvier 2009 par un beau
matin jeudi matin que je m'en vais
travailler je fais un dépassement
c'est alors que la voiture à l'avant
freine lise ouellet banques de se ranger
sur l'accotement
mais elle perd le contrôle
j'attends de 360 je sais combien puis
bon moment donné je me retrouve les yeux
je suis allée bien sûr l'autoroute puis
un camion qui roulait à au moins 130 km
à me frapper un face à face
c'est là que ma vie prend un autre sens
à partir de ce moment là lise ouellette
travaillait comme chef cosméticienne
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui se fait
maquiller
car elle a quitté son emploi après avoir
tenu le coup le temps les boulevards que
j'ai sont vraiment trop toujours la
présence et les auteurs d'aller chercher
les produits montbron il l'est plus
autant qu'avant
j'adorerais ça j'adore consomme ousamane
beaucoup énormément parce que ce travail
qui qui valorisait fracture des
vertèbres bras qui engourdissent me
gagne rien ne va plus
j'ai cassé piste est capable je voyais
plus jeter mon super u
bon ça vous suivez pu a plus rien qui
suivaient que vous emmenez sont la
goutte plomb à tous les jours après
votre travail en plus à rien vous dire
que ça irait peut-être manque aussi
gérer sous une bâche on était rendus aux
malades
même si elle fait ce qu'il faut elle est
incapable de retourner travailler
la dépression s'installe son médecin de
famille la met en arrêt de travail
mais la société de l'assurance auto
détermine qu'il peut travailler non pas
comme chef cosméticienne mais comme
commis au recouvrement
sa demande est l'ordinateur que je
connais pas de l'anglais que j'avais
peau est toujours assise apprendre à
recevoir des plaines déjà un journal ans
je pense pas que mon psy chic avait tenu
bon vu que j'étais en dépression
elle conteste entre temps la société
d'assurance auto lui verse 90 dollars
par mois
la différence entre son salaire d'avant
et celui qu'elle gagnerait si elle se
trouver un emploi de commis chez mes
chaînes de laisser des gens avec des 90
pièces par mois pour vivre
c'est ridicule ça n'a aucun sens cela
fait quatre ans qu'elle est ainsi sans
salaire ni réelle indemnités
les gens se retrouvent dans une
situation catastrophique et perdent leur
maison leur conjoint perdre tout
finalement l'avocat de madame ouellet
est venu nous rencontrer avec deux de
ses collègues d avocat émérite janyk
perron est depuis devenue juge à la cour
supérieure à 2 3 c'est presque un siècle
d'expérience à défendre les accidentés
ils parlent d'eux même voie qu'est ce
qui vous choque
est ce que une forme de mise en échec de
la loi même involontairement de cette
loi là qu'on voulait social qu'on
voulait expéditive rapide d'avoir sont
victimes d'un accident d'automobile
ils doivent pas non plus être victimes
de ce système d'indemnisation qui a été
créé pour que ça soit jugé rapidement
revenons à l'isoler l'automne dernier
après quatre ans d'attenté
elle est finalement entendu au tribunal
mais le matin même de l'audience
surprise mais le matin du 25 octobre
comme moi j'avais payé la boskoop le
seul pascal lacombe lui faire une
entente avec mon avocat je courais comme
de quoi qu il reconnaissait le trouble
d'adaptation
à la dernière minute on aimait ses
problèmes psychologiques mais la société
d'assurance auto demande encore du temps
son avocat refuse ses conséquences et
pas uniquement de l'admettre m'a
tellement de madame voir si on admet
dont vous serez les musées non c'est ont
la même et pourtant nous aussi puis vous
viendrez peut-être l'a41 lise ouellet
attend maintenant la décision du
tribunal se dépensent l'argent mais tu
dois attendre ses longs cils et entend
les lentes à l'entente se fatiguer et
stresser et épuisant j'ai assez pour
faire un dix dépression cette attente
n'est pas si exceptionnel
le parcours de l'accidenté qui conteste
une décision de la société de
l'assurance auto en est-on de
combattants la route est longue
la société de l'assurance auto à 90
jours pour répondre à votre demande si
vous êtes insatisfait et demander une
révision
la société prend huit mois et demi pour
répondre en moyenne
si vous demandez à être entendu au
tribunal ça va prendre deux ans et demi
pour avoir une date pour une première
audience
ce que dénonce la protectrice du citoyen
année après année de l'accident au
tribunal il s'est déjà écoulé trois ans
et demi en moyenne et il n'y a pas
encore de décision rendue est ce que le
problème c'est la société d'assurance
auto ou si le tribunal administratif du
québec
je pense d'une combinaison des deux
c'est à dire que à la société de
l'assurance automobile
en créant ce régime là de cette façon là
un contexte un chacun des décisions en
ne voulant jamais réglé global mais
d'aussi ont fait en sorte qu' on peut
et thierry un dossier pendant des années
des années et évidemment les victimes
par épuisement financier psychologique
vont abandonner une des causes du délai
et la présence de juges médecins avec le
juge avocat pour entendre l'accidenté or
les médecins se font rares on a besoin
sur nos formations pour les accidentés
d'un médecin si vous regardez nos
statistiques depuis 2010 la situation
est plus difficile dans le recrutement
des médecins
on est passé de 13 médecins temps plein
à cinq médecins temps plein puis la
courbe s'est inversée pour les médecins
temps partiel qui sont plus nombreux
qu'ils étaient en 2010
ceux qui auront la ténacité de se rendre
jusqu'au tribunal ont peu de chances de
gagner
nous avons découvert que 85 % perdent
selon la société de l'assurance auto
c'est bon signe
85% des décisions sont à faveur de la
société d'assurance auto comment vous
expliquez ça si 85% des décisions sont
maintenus c'est ça veut dire que dès le
départ les décisions que la société aux
prises danser dans ses nombreuses
décisions là parce qu'environ 300 milles
par année ont été généralement les
bonnes pourtant dans un autre tribunal
administratif celui des accidentés du
travail
seulement 43% perdent on parle de
tribunal indépendant dans les deux cas
on parle pas cependant des mêmes causes
ou des mêmes décisions rendues en terme
de ce qui se passe en termes nous on
s'est quand même des accidentés mais
c'est ce sont des accidentés
si vous me dites 85.5 pour ça c'est
parce qu'on aime bien pris une décision
départ est ce que ça veut dire que la
cnss tempo pris de bonnes décisions il
faut pas commentaires à cet effet lors
la présidente du tribunal administratif
du québec où sont entendus les
accidentés de la route veut aussi éviter
les comparaisons on a chacun nos
spécialités
je peux pas comparer qu'est ce qui se
fait au tapis quels sont les litiges qui
sont entendus est ce qu'ils ont toujours
besoin d'un médecin ce qui en ont pas
besoin
est-ce que l'évaluation se fait à la cns
ester de la même manière qu'elle se fait
à la saq est ce que c'est le même
processus jeu lignards je peux pas
comparer les deux régimes j'ai pas
suffisamment d'informations on peut
comparer aux doigts fait du truc du
droit comparé ici parce que on a les
moyens de le faire s'ils sont les
médecins qui se présente avec nous
devant les deux tribunaux et une
déchirure à la coiffe des rotateurs où
une fracture dorsale
c'est la même blessure avec les mêmes
médecins qui font les mêmes preuves mais
les résultats sont diamétralement
opposées
moumié travail c'est aussi dans ce
travail
[Musique]
après la pause vous allez voir pourquoi
les accidentés de la route sont
désavantagés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mélanie patenaude a accumulé les
expertises médicales
elle a été vue par trois médecins
experts choisis par la société de
l'assurance auto de sa poche et l'a payé
2 contre expertise 5300 dollars pour
être prête à contester un rapport
médical ne sera pas suffisant si on en
prend 2 après ça ça prend une expertise
mal à apprécier une contre-expertise
cette expertise
alors il faut avoir un complément
d'expertisé qui va venir parler de la
contre-expertise une route sans fin dont
les honoraires sont retrouvés
exponentielle astronomiques et qui en
bout de ligne mais quand la victime
obtient gain de cause
ces frais d'experts ne sont pas
remboursés tout petits montants qui est
remboursé mais donc la victime ne
récupère jamais toutes les sommes
d'argent qu'elle a investi dans ses
traits d'experts
sept ans après son accident elle attend
toujours d'être entendu au tribunal son
histoire à quelque chose de presque
comique elle travaillait à la société de
l'assurance auto comme évaluatrice
routière celle qui évalue si vous pouvez
avoir votre permis de conduire son
patron ne veut pas la voir au boulot
mais la société de l'assurance auto
considère qu'elle peut travailler à
temps plein la saq et des me disais que
je suis a pas travaillé et la saaq
employés à des bêtes peuvent aller à
paris 25 mai à patates au médecin veut
pas de travail pas clair j'ai tout de
même bouclé sa 70e josepha catch aux
besoins et des mois deux fois elle a
tenté un retour au travail après son
accident deux fois cela a été un échec
sera pas capable je ferai des
interventions pour voir enfin n'y a plus
personne car son permis
l'accident lui à creuser une entorse
cervicale ambert des migraines la main
droite
engourdi et une peur de conduire sur
l'autoroute
un an après son accident un médecin
expert choisi et payé par la société
l'assurance auto la considère en effet
inapte à faire son travail
mais la société en décide autrement et
médecins à ses indemnités
c'est la descente aux enfers j'étais
sans revenus de mai 2014 à avril 2000 ça
et c'est quand même quelque chose
moi je mangeais manger une fois par jour
des fois chotin chopin journée du
mariage est ma fille est en revanche
certain c'est l'importance ma fille à
l'avant manger cet accord
elle obtient finalement de l'aide
sociale mais tombe en dépression
c'est son fils à peine adulte qui vient
l'aider
qu'est ce que tu dis c'est beaucoup
voilà santé puisque logiquement -
décembre mais je voudrais bien kaka
t'appelle pour te lie depuis peu juste
par là ce n'était jamais aussi bien avec
comme parce que c'est un syndrome la
loyauté de vonage par thème je la
laissais com
dans ses parts dans son angoisse il
décide de lui payer une avocate
c'est pas le choix sinon peut pas le
pays se bat avec les petits trempe
caveau payer l'avocat était un enfant en
famille il je pense que rien alphone le
maire a pris son fils pourra demander de
l'argent là c'est tout le temps mal
pourquoi c'est si compliqué à faire
comprendre parce que si on accepte ses
blessures sérieuses mais je pense que
financièrement c'est un enjeu à long
terme pour la compagnie d'assurance
aussi comme je vous dis une gestion du
risque qu'une personne sur deux ne
rentrent pas accepter des offres
qu'arabes et il ne se rendra pas
jusqu'où on lui propose une conciliation
en présence d'un juge
six ans et demi après l'accident la juge
l'a carrément des à l'avocate a dit
j'aimerais qu'on prenne en considération
que cette dame la halle a besoin de ces
traitements physiques ces traitements
psychologiques
pat j'aimerais ça que les indemnisations
cette juge l'avait ému l'opinion qu'elle
trouvait que ça dure ce lundi devraient
être réglés et clairement ça c'est pas
passé parce que l'avocate à ce moment
lors du contentieux il est retourné à
son bureau et je pense qu'à lisent les
mains menottées par le médecin qui
travaille en interne le médecin à l
interne
dans ce cas ci il s'agit de luc marcoux
il travaille exclusivement pour la
société de l'assurance auto il a écrit
une note sur dossier c'est à dire sans
rencontrer madame patenaude ni appeler
son médecin traitant
il déclare qu'elle peut reprendre son
emploi d'évaluer trice routière un recul
important puisque trois ans plus tôt la
société convenait qu'elle en était
incapable
et c'est ça qui a été déterminant oui
comment ça je pense que l'opinion du
médecin expert alain terne de la saq en
priorité sur tout autre opinion
expertise médicale et la france ont
aussi eu la surprise au tribunal de
découvrir une note médicales du docteur
marc où je comprenais pas que ces
médecins lots donner un diagnostic sony
sans voir le client sans l'examiner
sans lui poser des questions je trouvais
ça bizarre
selon cette note le diagnostic
d'entorses cervicales a été posée trop
tard sept mois après l'accident pour que
cela soit dû à l'accident d'auto
mais voici ce qu'il aurait pris s'il
avait appelé le chirurgien m'a depuis le
début après son accès avec l'automobile
et sur la france est toujours plein au
niveau cervical que c'était augmenté
puis la résonance mais ces cas
effectivement démontré des lésions
importantes que la nécessité une
intervention chirurgicale par le neuro
chirurgie où un couple russe le plus
haut clocher du coude et c'est très
douloureux douloureux comme un
aspirateur
au tribunal
monsieur la france n'a pas d'avocat mais
la juge elle-même questionne
l'objectivité du docteur marc où il est
en effet plutôt difficile de concevoir
que le docteur nakouh puisse offrir une
opinion totalement objective impartiale
et sans aucun parti pris
alors qu'il exerce sa profession de
façon exclusive pour le compte de la saq
cela jugera pape assure le monsieur
le médecin l'a s'acquitter pour l'aca
qui pour le poste il m'avait pas donné
la juge écarte la note médical et donne
raison à monsieur la france
ces problèmes de coût sont dus à
l'accident d'auto il faut savoir que
cela ne s'est pas passé au tribunal où
sont entendus les accidentés de la route
mais à celui pour des accidentés du
travail
on se souvient que monsieur lafrance
avait subi un accident de travail peu de
temps avant son accident d'auto deux
tribunaux administratifs avec des
résultats forts différents
rappelez-vous les accidentés de la route
perdre dans 85% des cas les accidentés
du travail dans 43% docteur marc où nous
a fait savoir par son employeur qu'il
refuse de nous accorder une entrevue
vous présentez des notes médical d'une
opinion sur dossier nous personne que
jamais vu et qu'il refusait dans
d'autres tribunaux administratifs pour
se faire présenter ça dans le processus
qui nous occupe avec le tribunal
administratif c'est ce sont des éléments
que la société peut peut déposer
maintenant si éventuellement il y avait
des avait des changements c'est sûr
qu'on va s'y plier éventuellement les
notes médical ça fait partie du dossier
mais c'est pas prépondérant d'endosser
ma question c'est pourquoi les présenter
puisque c'est pas un expert indépendant
puis qu à d'autres tribunaux ont dit que
pour qu'on devrait avoir ça mais on peut
pas prêcher la saq de faire sa preuve
autre différence la place qui est faite
aux médecins traitants dans la loi sur
la loi sur des extraits y on donne une
préséance aux médecins traitants ce
qu'on ne fait pas la société de
l'assurance automobile et même on ignore
les rapports des médecins traitants qui
pourtant justifie souvent la nature du
diagnostic est aussi la présence de
juges médecins ce qui change la donne
lui qu'une formation médicale et
scientifique au toujours tendance à
rechercher évidemment une preuve
médicale qui tend vers plus la probable
des scientifiques que je redis je me
suis rendu compte avec les années que
malgré tout les verts les centaines
d'heures que je mets dans les deux sens
dans les dossiers que les jugements
comportent ne tient pas compte de ces
éclairages alain bissonnette est un des
rares médecins spécialisés en douleur
chronique
il est souvent demandé pour faire des
expertises ou dessus de douleur ici ils
se il vient de décider que c'était fini
un des derniers dossiers que j'ai eues
on me demandait tout les différents
articles qui existe
au niveau scientifique mondiale pour
confirmer ce que je veux dire et même
plus que ça un tribunal juge je me dis
si vous me donnez pas l'article de 1995
à propos d'un petit questionnaire de bas
de page
nous ne rien entendre on pas la cause je
pense qu'encore une fois ils réussissent
avec cet argument je reviens toujours
sur cet argument de certitude
scientifique se laver les mains des
séquelles provoquées par un accident
automobile
les accidentés de la route ne sont pas
au bout de leurs peines
la suite de notre enquête après la pause
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
gérard la france n'est pas au bout de
ses peines même s'il a gagné au tribunal
son dos y est retourné à la société de
l'assurance auto pour déterminer la
gravité des séquelles aux coûts et donc
le montant forfaitaire à recevoir cac
havas façon violente ou tre sa coiffeuse
à dhiba en gérant qui arrive deuxième
[Rires]
dernièrement mélanie patenaude s'est
fait proposer une nouvelle entente à
l'amiable inférieure à celle qu'elle
avait reçu il ya trois ans voyons donc
comment est-ce qu'on peut m'offrir en
2015 90 même pour aujourd'hui
soixante-trois mille
elle attend toujours une date d'audience
entre temps elle a fondé sur facebook
une association pour les droits des
accidentés
c'est à partir de là que j'ai commencé à
mieux ali moralement parce que là je me
disais ben joyent aider les gens je peux
pas lui donner le salaire mais je peux
les écouter de les comprendre parce que
moi je sais quoi
si ces couacs haqqani ce que tu veux
lise ouellet viennent gagner en cours
neuf ans après ces accidents c'est bien
qu'elle va recevoir quatre ans et demi
d'indemnités rétroactivement une fois
tout rembourser il ne lui restera pas
grand chose sinon la fierté d'être allé
jusqu'au bout
ils veulent vraiment con constament
cancon loge tout qu'on desserre propos
key a payé pourquoi ça existe
cette assurance lors que madame payette
avait créé en bouillie moellons
[Musique]